Schönen guten Tag, mein Name ist Satiqi. Ich bin auf dieser Station als Assistenzarzt tätig und würde gerne mit Ihnen das Aufnahmegespräch führen.
Bitte sagen Sie mir Bescheid oder fragen Sie nach, wenn Sie etwas nicht verstehen.
Zuerst bräuchte ich von Ihnen ein paar persönliche Daten. Wie heißen Sie?
Ich heiße Patricia Gerber.
Könnten Sie bitte Ihren Vor- und Nachnamen buchstabieren?
Ja, Patricia schreibt sich P-A-T-R-I-Z-I-A. Patricia.
Und Gerber der Nachname G-E-R-B-E-R. Gerber.
Vielen Dank Frau Gerber.
Wie alt sind Sie?
46.
Wann sind Sie geboren?
Am 3. März 1980.
Wie groß sind Sie?
1,72 Meter.
Wie viel wiegen Sie aktuell?
61 Kilo.
Was fühlst du heute zu uns? Welche Beschwerden haben Sie, Frau Gerber?
Seit drei Wochen geht es mir nicht gut. Ich schlafe ganz schlecht. Ich schwitze stark.
Ich bin sehr nervös. Meine Familie sagt, ich bin so nervös.
Ich kann mich schlecht konzentrieren. Dann habe ich jetzt auch oft Durchfall.
Das kenne ich gar nicht. Normalerweise habe ich regelmäßig einmal Stuhlgang.
Aber ich habe jetzt ziemlich oft sehr viel Durchfall.
Wie oft haben Sie Durchfall?
Ja, es war gestern zum Beispiel fünfmal.
Zwischen drei und fünfmal.
Alles klar. Ich verstehe Ihre Beschwerden.
Haben Sie diese Beschwerden langsam oder plötzlich begonnen?
Langsam.
Haben Sie irgendwo Schmerzen?
Nein, Schmerzen habe ich nicht.
Fühlen Sie sich abgeschlagen oder müde?
Ja, durch meinen schlechten Schlaf bin ich nicht leistungsfähig.
Ich fühle mich schon müde.
Haben Sie früher diese Beschwerden gehabt?
Nein, sowas habe ich noch nie gehabt.
Haben Sie etwas dagegen eingenommen?
Nein, ich wüsste nicht was.
Haben Sie Herztragen, Herzklopfen oder Atemnot?
Atemnot habe ich nicht. Aber ich habe bemerkt, dass mein Puls etwas schneller geht als sonst.
Ich habe sonst immer so Puls gehabt. Man soll ja mal zwischendurch seinen Puls kontrollieren zwischen 70 und 80.
Jetzt ist er so 90 bis 100 schneller als sonst.
Seit wann haben Sie diese Beschwerden?
Ja, auch so. Ungefähr seit der Zeit. Seit einigen drei Wochen.
Zwei Wochen, drei Wochen.
Sind Ihre Beine geschwollen?
Nein.
Haben Sie im Halsbereich eine Schwellung bemerkt?
Nein, habe ich nicht bemerkt. Ich habe auch keine Schmerzen, keine Schwellungen bemerkt.
Haben Sie hervorragende Augen bemerkt?
Das ist mir nicht aufgefallen.
Ist Ihnen in der letzten Zeit Haarausfall bemerkt?
Ich habe immer ein bisschen Haarausfall in den letzten Jahren. Aber das ist mir nicht aufgefallen. Nicht mehr als sonst.
Ist Ihr Haut trocken oder kalt?
Nein, kalt ist er nicht. Er warme. Ich habe mal die Temperatur gemessen.
Da hatte ich in den letzten Tagen immer fast 38.
Normalerweise messe ich das zwischendurch mal sonst eher 37. 36, 8, 37. Aber jetzt habe ich fast 38.
Wo im Körper haben Sie das Fieber gemessen?
Im Mund.
Wann haben Sie das gemessen?
Abends.
Seit wann haben Sie Fieber?
Das weiß ich nicht genau. Ich habe das erst seit einigen Tagen gemessen.
Vielleicht seit fünf Tagen habe ich es gemessen. Vielleicht ist es schon etwas länger.
Haben Sie Heißschmerzen, Schnupfen?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Fühlen Sie sich antifasslos?
Ich bin nervös. Ich bin schnell gereizt und antifasslos eher nicht.
Haben Sie Bauchkrämpfe oder Bauchschmerzen?
Sie haben ja schon gesagt, dass Sie Durchfall haben.
Nein, Bauchkrämpfe habe ich nicht.
Wie sah der Durchfall aus?
Der ist so wässrig, schleimig und hell.
Ok, ich verstehe.
Haben Sie Schüttelfrost oder ein starkes Krankheitsgefühl?
Schüttelfrost habe ich nicht. Aber Krankheitsgefühl schon. Mir geht es ja nicht gut.
Gibt es bestimmte Auslöser für diese Beschwerden?
Haben Sie etwas bemerkt?
Ich habe keine Erklärung. Ich weiß das nicht, weil ich so etwas noch nie gehabt habe.
Schwitzen Sie oft in der Nacht?
Ja, aber erst seit drei Wochen. Vorher habe ich das nicht gehabt.
Sie haben ja schon gesagt, dass Sie Schlepplichkeit haben.
Wie ist Ihr Schlaf in der Nacht?
Schlecht. Ich kann nicht gut schlafen, weil ich so nervös und aufgeregt bin.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Einschlafen oder Durchschlafen?
Beides. Einschlafen und Durchschlafen.
Wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Sehr gut.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserlassen?
Nein, beim Wasserlassen habe ich keine Probleme.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Stuhlgang außer Durchfall?
Nein, nur den Durchfall eben.
Haben Sie in der letzten Zeit ungewollt ab- oder zugenommen?
Ja, ich habe fünf Kilo Gewicht verloren in den letzten drei Wochen.
Leiden Sie an irgendwelchen chronischen Erkrankungen, wie z.B. Brütopthrop, Zuckerkrankheit?
Ich habe allergisches Asthma. Ich bin allergisch auf Hausstaub und auf Pollen.
Jetzt auch gerade wieder der Pollen, der macht mir schon zu schaffen.
Da muss ich immer meinen Asthma-Spray nehmen.
Vor zehn Jahren hatte ich eine Schilddrüsenunterfunktion.
Ich nehme regelmäßig ein Medikament ein.
Darunter ist die Unterfunktion wieder normalisiert.
Das wird auch kontrolliert. Das letzte Mal war das vor einem Jahr.
Welche Medikamente nehmen Sie ein?
Ich nehme für die Schilddrüse ein L-Tiroxin.
In welcher Dosierung?
Dahinter steht 75. Da nehme ich eine Tablette morgens.
Und ich nehme für das Asthma-Spray Vianispray ein.
Da nehme ich zweimal pro Tag.
Wie schreibt man das?
V-I-A-N-I.
Da ist Cortison drin.
Alles klar.
Haben Sie noch weitere Erkrankungen?
Nein, sonst habe ich keine Erkrankungen.
Nehmen Sie L-Tiroxin-Tabletten regelmäßig?
Ja, jeden Morgen.
Nehmen Sie bei Bedarf andere Medikamente ein?
Nein, sonst nehme ich keine Medikamente ein.
Sind Sie schon einmal operiert worden?
Als Kind wurde ich 11 Jahre alt.
Da wurde ich am Blinddarm operiert.
Vor 28 Jahren hatte ich einen Kaiserschnitt.
Vor zwei Jahren hatte ich eine Operation am linken Handgelenk.
Ein Nerv war eingeklemmt.
Ich hatte immer in den Fingern Kribbel.
Die Finger schliefen immer ein.
Dann wurde ein Kribbelnbewerb operiert.
Ein kleiner Schnitt am Handgelenk.
Dann ist es gut geworden.
Haben Sie noch weitere Operationen?
Nein, keine Operationen.
Vor sechs Wochen schickte mich meine Frau eine Gynäkologin zum Urologen.
Sie hat eine Untersuchung meiner Nieren gemacht.
Das war nicht angenehm.
Ich habe ein Kontrastmittel in die Vene bekommen.
Das Mittel habe ich nicht gut vertragen.
Ich konnte akustisch nicht verstehen.
Können Sie noch einmal erklären, was vor sechs Wochen passiert ist?
Meine Gynäkologin hat eine Überweisung zum Urologen geschrieben.
Sie wollte gerne, dass die Nieren untersucht werden.
Dann wurde bei der Untersuchung einer Röntgen gemacht.
Ich hatte eine Kontrastmittel.
Das war sehr unangenehm.
Ich war da übel.
Das war vor sechs Wochen.
Wurde eine Diagnose gestellt?
Der Urologe hat nichts Auffälliges gefunden.
Welche Beschwerden hatten Sie vor sechs Wochen?
Ich hatte zwischendurch Beschwerden beim Wasserlassen.
Ich dachte, das wäre etwas für die Frauenärztin.
Die fand aber alles in Ordnung.
Sie hat gesagt, sie überweise sicherheitshalber zu einem Urologe.
Sie haben schon gesagt, dass sie hauptstammt mit allergie und Polenallergie.
Welche Polenallergie?
Die Polen fliegen zurzeit von vielen Bäumen.
Von den Bäumen der Birke und Erle.
Ich bin getestet worden.
Das Wetter ist schön und es ist windig.
Das macht mir schwer zu schaffen.
Das ist nicht angenehm.
Wie äußert sich diese Allergie?
Asthma. Meine Schleimhäute sind angeschwollen.
Meine Nase läuft. Meine Augen sind gereizt.
Hauptsächlich Asthma.
Haben Sie Unvertretung?
Nein.
Sind Sie vollständig geimpft?
Ja.
Ich war vor zwei Monaten in Thailand.
Ich war vorher beim Arzt.
Er hat geschaut, dass die Impfung für die Nase nicht so hoch ist.
Er hat geschaut, dass die Impfungen für Thailand vorhanden sind.
Das war so.
Rauchen Sie?
Nein.
Wegen dem Asthma rauche ich nicht.
Haben Sie früher geraucht?
Ja.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ich trinke mal ein Glas Wein.
Zwei, dreimal pro Woche.
Konsumieren Sie Drogen? Nein.
Gibt es in Ihrer Familie chronische Erkrankungen?
Mein Vater ist 78 Jahre alt.
Er ist herzkrank.
Er hatte vor zwei Jahren eine Katheteruntersuchung.
Er hat zwei Plastikröhrchen in die Herzkranzgefäße bekommen.
Er hat auch noch hohen Blutdruck.
Meine Mutter ist 76 Jahre alt.
Sie hat schwere Arthrose in beiden Knien.
Sie muss jetzt am Rollator laufen, weil sie das nicht anders schafft.
Ich habe noch eine Schwester.
Sie ist 48 Jahre alt.
Sie wurde vor einem Jahr die Gallenblase entfernt.
Ihre Schwester?
Ja.
Was machen Sie beruflich?
Ich bin Busfahrerin.
Gibt es in der Arbeit viel Stress?
Ich mache den Beruf gerne.
Ich kann Ihnen eine psychologische Unterstützung empfehlen.
Ich möchte wissen, was ich jetzt habe.
Warum ich Gewicht abgenommen habe.
Ich kann Sie gut verstehen.
Sind Sie verheiratet? Ja.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, ich hatte ein Kaiserschnittgeburt vor 28 Jahren.
Sie leben in seiner Familie.
Mit meinem Mann zusammen.
Unsere Tochter wohnt nicht mehr bei uns.
Sie ist 28 Jahre alt.
Sie ist schon in der Familie.
Sie ist schon länger ausgezogen.
Alles klar.
Ich habe alle meine Fragen gestellt.
Sie sind mit unserem Gespräch fertig.
Haben Sie noch Fragen?
Ich möchte wissen, was ich habe.
Ich kann Sie gut verstehen.
Ich möchte Sie wissen, warum Sie sich so schnell wissen.
Ich möchte keine vorgelegenen Füße ziehen.
Ich kann Ihnen etwas genauer sagen.
Ich brauche alle Informationen.
Ich werde Sie körperlich untersuchen.
Dann wird Sie Blut abnehmen.
Dann wird Sie anschließend weiter betrachtet werden.
Dann werden Sie weitere Untersuchungen durchführen.
Wir müssen alle Ergebnisse abwarten.
Sobald wir alle Ergebnisse haben, werden wir alles besprechen.
Und gemeinsam das weitere Vorgehen planen.
Das können wir so machen.
Dann haben Sie jetzt einige Minuten Zeit, sich vorzubereiten.
Was die Ursachen sein können.
Ich möchte Sie wissen, wie viel Zeit die Patientin hat.
Gibt es von den Kolleginnen und Kollegen noch Fragen?
Darf ich?
Haben Sie in nächster Zeit Cytern der Hände bemerkt?
Warme Hände?
Mir ist ja sehr warm.
Und meine Körpertemperatur allgemein fühle ich mich sehr warm.
Cytren?
Das ist mir bisher nicht aufgefallen.
Ich habe es aber noch nicht richtig überprüft.
Befinden Sie sich in Wechseljahren?
Nein, in den Wechseljahren befinde ich mich noch nicht.
Ist Ihre Periode regelmäßig?
Sie hätte eigentlich letzte Woche sein sollen.
Sie ist bisher aber noch nicht eingetreten.
Danke.
Darf ich fragen?
Ja bitte.
Nach der Nierenuntersuchung mit Kontrast, haben Sie bemerkt, dass Ihre Urinmenge vermindert?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Darf ich?
Haben Sie in letzter Zeit vermehrten Durst?
Als gewöhnlich?
Das habe ich nicht verstanden. Können Sie das wiederholen?
Haben Sie in letzter Zeit vermehrten Durst?
Nein, eigentlich nicht.
Ich versuche immer ausreichend viel zu trinken.
Aber das habe ich jetzt nicht bemerkt.
Sie haben schon gesagt, dass Ihr Appetit sehr gut ist.
Haben Sie Heißhungerattacke?
Manchmal könnte ich schon noch mehr essen als gewöhnlich.
Aber so richtig Heißhunger, ja.
Aber ich habe in letzter Zeit eigentlich immer Hunger.
Danke.
Der Kollege Arndt hat es schon.
Der Kollege arbeitet noch und brütet.
Darf ich fragen?
Haben Sie in letzter Zeit Ihre Schilddrüsefunktion gemessen lassen?
Normalerweise wird die Schilddrüse einmal im Jahr untersucht.
Auch mit den ganzen Werten.
Das war vor einem Jahr.
Es wäre jetzt wieder fällig.
Ich habe die Schilddrüse in den letzten Wochen und Monaten nicht untersucht.
Könnten wir schon anfangen?
Oder brauchen Sie noch etwas?
Schönen guten Tag, Herr Oberers.
Ich möchte Ihnen einen neuen Patienten vorstellen.
Es geht um Frau Patricia Gerber.
Die ist 46 Jahre alt.
Sie ist 1,72 Meter groß.
Sie wiegt aktuell 160 Kilogramm.
Sie?
Sie stürzt sich vor wegen
seit drei Wochen bestehender Schleifigkeit,
innerer Unruhe, Nervosität.
Sie stürzt sich vor wegen
seit drei Wochen bestehender Schleifigkeit,
innerer Unruhe, Nervosität.
Sie stürzt sich vor wegen
seit drei Wochen bestehender Schleifigkeit,
innerer Unruhe, Nervosität.
Sie stürzt sich vor wegen
seit drei Wochen bestehender Schleifigkeit,
innerer Unruhe, Nervosität.
Sie stürzt sich vor wegen
seit drei Wochen bestehender Schleifigkeit,
innerer Unruhe, Nerv הא.
Sie shirt net
Düsne wurden verneint.
Außerdem berichtet sie über eine Fieber bis 38 Abend oral gemessene Fieber.
Darüber hinaus erwähnt sie die Schweizer Hyperhydrose seit drei Wochen.
Die vegetative Anamnese ergibt Insomnie in Form von Einschlafstörungen und Durchschlafstörungen.
Sie hat einen Gewichtsverlust von 5 Kilo innerhalb von drei Wochen.
In der medizinischen Vorgeschichte finden sich Asthma Bronchiale.
Unser Patient hat eine Flügelallergie, die sich mit Rhinokonjunktivitis und Düsne äußert.
Außerdem leitet sie vor zehn Jahren an einer Hypotriose.
Wie lange leidet sie an einer Hypotriose?
Vor zehn Jahren.
Wird das behandelt?
Zur Behandlung der Hypotriose nimmt sie 75 mg Morgens.
Mikrogramm.
Bezüglich der Medikation nimmt sie Vianispray zweimal pro Tag.
Hat sie denn nur eine Unverträglichkeit auf Pollen, Frühblüher oder noch eine andere Unverträglichkeit?
Hausstaubmilbe.
Das ist eine häufige Situation, dass viele Menschen allergisch auf Hausstaubmilbe sind.
Hat sie sonst noch Operationen in ihrem Leben gehabt?
Im Alter von elf Jahren hat sie sich einer Appendiktomie unterzogen.
Vor 28 Jahren hat sie sich eine Sextuiocesaria unterzogen.
Und sonstige Operationen noch?
Ja.
Vor zwei Jahren hat sie sich einen karpatularen Syndrom erlitten.
Weshalb sie eine Operation durchgeführt wurde?
Sie können einfacher sagen, vor zwei Jahren wurde sie an einem Karpaltunnelsyndrom operiert.
Das reicht als Information.
Karpaltunnelsyndrom. Gut. Aber wichtig ist, sie haben die Diagnose richtig benannt und das ist alles gut.
Gibt es Auffälligkeiten in der Familienadamnese?
Der Vater der Patienten leidet an einer KHK.
Wie alt ist der Vater?
Der Vater ist 78 Jahre alt.
Vor zwei Jahren wurde bei ihm eine Coronarengiografie durchgeführt.
Und zwei Stands implantiert.
Was hat der Vater noch?
Der Vater der Patienten leidet an arterieller Hypertonie.
Und die Mutter?
Die Mutter der Patienten leidet an bilaterale Konarthrose.
Deswegen läuft sie mit Rolator.
Gibt es Geschwister?
Unsere Patientin hat eine Schwester.
Die 46 Jahre alt ist.
Vor einem Jahr wurde sie Cholesthystikthomie unterzogen.
Die Schwester wurde Cholesthystektomiert.
Was ist Ihre Verdachtsdiagnose?
Die amnestischen Angaben deuten am ehesten auf eine Hyperthyreose hin.
Differentialdiagnostik kommen.
Was würden Sie sagen, gibt es eine Ursache für die Hyperthyreose?
Was kann für eine Ursache da sein?
Vielleicht nimmt die Patientin ihre Elteroxintablette.
Vielleicht nimmt sie zu viel Elteroxin.
Vielleicht ist 75 mg überdosiert.
Aber der Patient nimmt die Medikamente regelmäßig.
Es kann sein, dass sie zu viel genommen hat.
Denken Sie noch mal in der Anamnese.
Vor 6 Wochen hatte die Patientin eine Untersuchung.
Sie untersuchte vor 6 Wochen bei der Urologie eine Untersuchung mit Kontrastmittel.
Es gab eine Kontrastmitteluntersuchung.
Wahrscheinlich war es ein sogenanntes IV-Pylogramm.
Eine Röntgenkontrastdarstellung der Nieren.
Es war früher eine sehr verbreitete Untersuchungsmethode.
Es ist in den letzten Jahren deutlich weniger geworden.
Es ist leider oft mit einem Risiko verbunden.
Diese Kontrastmittel enthalten mit Unterjod.
Es kann zu einer Hyperthyreose führen.
Vielleicht ist die Patientin zu hoch eingestellt mit dem Elteroxin.
Die letzte Kontrolle war vor einem Jahr.
Das kann auch sein, dass es zu einer Hyperthyreosis-Faktitia kommt.
Alle klinischen Symptome sprechen eher für eine Hyperthyreose.
Jetzt bedenken Sie noch mal etwas, was Sie unbedingt im Auge behalten müssen.
Denken Sie bei der Patientin an die Reiseanamnese.
Sie war vor zwei Monaten in Thailand.
Deswegen hatte sie alle Impfungen.
Während der Reise hatten Sie vielleicht Darminfektionen.
Hören Sie mich?
Herr Heiko, hören Sie mich?
Wir hören Sie.
Herr Heiko hat es wohl kaputt.
Hallo?
Sind Sie noch da?
Hallo.
Ich höre Sie jetzt.
Ich habe eine Überlegung.
Meine Internetverbindung, mein Router ist hier.
Ich bin hier auswärts.
Die Patientin war vor zwei Monaten verreist.
Wo war sie?
Vor zwei Monaten war unsere Patientin in Thailand.
Deswegen hatten sie Darminfektionen.
Sie haben malaria?
Das habe ich keine weiteren Informationen.
Sie müssen an Malaria denken.
Sie müssen zumindest ausschließen.
Sie waren vor zwei Monaten in Thailand.
Sie haben nach Impfungen gefragt.
Sie haben eine Malaria-Profilaxe betrieben.
Sie hatten keine Malaria-Profilaxe.
Jede Diarrhea, die in so einem Zeitraum
noch später auftritt, muss man ausschließen.
Auch wenn die klinischen Symptome alle auf eine hyperthyriose hindeuten.
Das war eine kleine Falle.
Ich glaube, dass die Hauptdiagnose Verdacht auf hyperthyriose ist.
Aber bedenken Sie bitte die Reiseanamnese,
dass Sie nicht eventuell eine Malaria übersehen.
Sie messen vielleicht im Blut ein niedriges TSH und hohe FT3, FT4-Werte.
Was für eine hyperthyriose spricht.
Die Patientin kann eventuell beides haben.
4-5 mal Diarrho am Tag mit 38 Grad.
Es muss nicht immer Fieber sein.
Bitte dran denken.
Ich hoffe, Sie haben mich gut verstanden.
Mein Internet hat sich wieder erholt.
Ich bin mit einem mobilen Router unterwegs.
Sie haben das trotzdem gut gemacht.
Vielen Dank.
Ich hätte für eine Prüfung gar keine Bedenken bei Ihnen.
Ich kann Sie gut verstehen.
Sie können sich gut ausdrücken.
Machen Sie es bitte in der Formulierung der Sätze immer einfach.
Natürlich muss man, ich sehe hier unten gerade,
wenn eine Diarrho da ist in der Häufigkeit, sie ist zwar nicht blutig,
sie macht keine Schmerzen,
aber man muss natürlich den Stuhl auch auf pathogene Keime untersuchen.
Das ist völlig klar.
Gerade bei Rückkehren aus Thailand zum Beispiel.
Das denke ich dann in der Klinik auch selbstverständlich.
Stuhl auf pathogene Keime,
dicker Tropfen bezüglich Malaria,
aber Schwerpunkt sicherlich Richtung Schilddrüse.
Da stimme ich Ihnen zu.
Aber bitte die anderen Dinge nicht aus den Augen verlieren.
Ja, gut.
Ja, vielen Dank.
Hat mir Spaß gemacht.
Vielen Dank für die Mitarbeit, meine Kollegen.
Ich würde aber wieder sagen,
wir sehen uns dann wieder regulär nächste Woche Donnerstag.
Gut, dann sage ich mal tschüss.
Machen Sie es gut.